so we we have a clip from genius
actually I think it's the trailer but
it's a particularly good trailer because
it I think it gives a
a sense of the whole sweep of the movie
but perhaps you're just for people
haven't seen it mmm Carol just said it's
about Maxwell Perkins and Thomas Wolfe
but perhaps you could explain a little
more than nature of their relationship
certainly I'll try - Maxwell Perkins at
the end of the 1920s was the leading
editor at scribblers & Sons here in New
York promptly if I go wrong he was good
and
[Music]
a manuscript came across his desk which
took him a weekend to read through at
the end of which he he felt he had
discovered a new American literary great
and he embarks on a relationship with
Thomas Wolfe as editor as his editor
that brought these two men together on
an extraordinary journey both as
collaborators as friends as surrogate
father and son
and indeed drew them both away from the
the female relationships that they were
in and it's an investigation really of
the creative process of editing a book
of writing a book it looks at the
essence of what genius is is genius in
in collaboration is it in the hands of
one man or another it can be someone be
a genius of friendship can someone be
just a genius of collaboration and it's
also an opportunity to look at
certainly from a British point of view
the the
the life of these two great men who seem
to have slipped somewhat into history
shadows let's look at the clip
[Music]
so that wasn't the trailer after all but
it I think it's a well-chosen and it
gets at the heart of their relationship
and I have to say that this is a movie
but I've brought a lot of personal
interest to because they mentioned I've
spent many much more of my life as an
editor need as a fiction editor than I
have as a writer and it always seemed to
me that editors were somewhat unsung
there aren't many movies about errors in
fact I think they're wrong this is only
the second and the first one is I
mentioned it to Jude in the in the green
room
the only other movie I know about netter
is wolf if you remember with Jack
Nicholson is an editor but we don't
actually get to see him doing
because his main job is being a werewolf
but it interests me
the the movie is based on a very good
biography by Scott Berg biography of
Maxwell Perkins that came out about 30
years ago and
so I'm curious so that
it takes all this time for someone to
screw up the courage of the interest to
make a movie about this these two people
and it's occurs to me that that when it
happens
it's a British theater director does it
the movie is directed by michael
grandage who in case people here don't
know he's he's easily that the greatest
British theater director of this
generation and but this is his first
movie that's right so I'm curious you
know he could have do you know what what
was it
yeah I understand that the the order of
events went like this Scott obviously
wrote the biography of Maxwell Perkins
called Maxwell Perkins editor of genius
I believe John Logan brilliant
screenwriter and Academy award-winning
screenwriter I believe playwright - yep
who had work with Michael so there was a
relationship there they did work
together on read which I believe but was
performed here John
read the book read Scott's book and
really pleaded with him to have a chance
to write the screenplay that
that happened almost 10 15 years ago I
believe that long the script was then as
many great scripts are as you may well
know sort of passed around Hollywood
like a volleyball
I believe it land it was a brilliant
screenplay but that doesn't necessarily
mean it's going to be made immediately
you know there was obviously it was a
subject matter that wasn't immediately
commercial so it was as I said it was
passed around Hollywood I believe it
landed in various directors laps and and
was either looked at or investigated to
be made was never made which again
happens all the time along that journey
it picked up the interest of Colin Firth
and Colin
if you see it recognize I think I've not
a kindred spirit but something in
Maxwell Perkins that he really felt he
he had a handle on so he was attached
and I think I think eventually the
rights went back to John Logan and he at
this stage was obviously it was it was a
passion piece and was just very keen to
have it made and Michael and he having
collaborated he knew that Michael was
just interested finally director film
and was looking at reading scripts this
landed on his script and finally it
happened I was I was wondering and I
guess we need to ask Michael but it
struck me that he may have been
interested in part because the job of
being a director is not dissimilar yeah
the job of being an editor right I think
he was curious
I think he recognized that there was
first of all it was a it was a piece
about performance it was a piece not to
limit it but it was a piece it was a
it's a domestic piece it takes place in
rooms and offices and is very much about
the spoken word so I think for a theater
director dipping one's his toe into this
into that the medium of film for the
first time it felt that it was an area
he was experienced in and could bring
his experience to but you're right and
I'm you know I spent the day doing QA
with him so I can quote him quite
succinctly Innes I know that he
recognized in their relationship in the
relationship of a creative well they're
both creative men he recognized I
suppose the collaboration between
someone who is taking a sort of creative
expression a creative purge if you like
and somehow steering administering
guidance and percolating it into a more
refined State and indeed the police
raises that that question I think it's
not just obviously our on one level it's
very much a piece about the great works
of Thomas Wolfe
and what it took to put them on on the
page and indeed in the shots but it's
equally about the collaboration of
creative minds and what is it and where
is G where does genius exist in that so
what attracted you to this michael
grandage I I just finished I done
I played Hamlet wit for him and I played
Henry v for him and when he said he was
busy putting together this film I was
really curious to know how this this
this hugely experienced and adept
theater director was going to take to
the medium of film and I remember he
would he would come and talk to me
during the run of Henry the fifth in my
dressing room I towards the end of the
run and was always talking about various
actors who could play Thomas Wolfe and I
remember to answer a few weeks thinking
you know he'd still hasn't asked me to
read this script what's it done wrong
and eventually it was almost I I think I
actually saw the night where he was sort
of talking about these actions and then
kind of thought oh maybe you should read
it and he let me read it and so yes in
in truth I didn't really know who Thomas
Wolfe was and like many many people I
assumed he'd written bonfire of the
vanities and I was just very excited
about wearing white suits and kind of
hats
[Laughter]
no I didn't really but III was excited
because Michael was involved and I
thought here's a man who I I felt very
very safe in his hands and taken on some
some pretty meaty parts with and come
out feeling fulfilled and really happy
happy with the experience and then I am
you know through it through John Logan's
wonderful screenplay I was introduced to
the world of Thomas Wolfe this
extraordinary character and on the page
it was clear here was a an enormous
character to sink one's teeth into
boolean and lecherous and drunken and
loud but brilliant and driven motivated
I mean it was it would literally jumped
off the page and my first questions were
always it was easy you should be sure he
was this big he was this loud and my
only concern was that he was apparently
six foot seven and I'm 511 if I'm lucky
when I stand up really straight you know
but of course the scale of the man was
very much in the piece and that in the
heart of what John Logan had captured
from from what he knew of Wolff and so
that's where it all started yeah did you
did you eventually read Woolf he's not
read much in this country anymore I
don't think I believed he was he was he
was dropped from the syllabus in the 70s
possibly because of his will I've heard
because of certain racist elements of
his writing and has kind of drifted out
of and the writing is also I mean the
writing is like the personality and and
you see this in the movie it's huge yeah
and it's not everyone's taste it no
quite
III did read I did because apart from
anything it was you know I think if
you're playing a writer you have to them
you have to be a familiar with the works
but also fortunately a huge amount of
his writing is biographical and so
there's this mine of detailed insight
into how he who he was how he felt I
mean starting literally from birth I
mean it even I think the opening chapter
look homeward angel takes place in his
mother's womb
and proceed it's too bad that the clip
we saw it doesn't show what you do with
this part I mean which seems to me to
perfectly kind of characterize his
writing it's your portrayal it's big
it's exuberant its verges and it's
almost out of control
yeah not it's easy and as you say he's
he's he's a drunk he's sentimental he's
lecherous full of feelings uncontrol is
that a hard kind of character to play
how do you how do you do that without
becoming yourself too much of a muchness
you have to
again you have to trust your director I
think because you we were fortunate to
have time to rehearse
but you're aware of the piece as a whole
and the scale if you like or the on the
the touchstones that you you want to
reach at any given time in the
performance which given a part like
thomas wolfe or a man like thomas wolfe
abroad you know you want to go from
there are scenes where he will cry one
minute and be ecstatically happy on the
next literally that the toss of a coin
so you're certainly looking at this the
spectrum of these characters and
thinking about gosh okay well i think i
can map this and i can get there
emotionally a lot of it is about
releasing the emotional handbrake that
one normally conducts oneself with and
really we're pouring yourself into it
physically but I read the reason I back
to having a direct heat and Trust is
because personally might the what the
one voice I always have was gosh is this
too much is this am I am i overdoing it
but of course if you're a director with
an objective point of view and you need
a scene to carry the characters around
him in certain directions or to react in
a certain way the directors of course is
saying no you need to go there otherwise
they're not responding correctly you
know and what was wonderful about this
piece is that the other extreme you have
Maxwell Perkins who by all accounts was
incredibly contained and considerate and
reliable caught the same train home
every night for 30 years I believe
lived a very tame life and so I think
Michael saw it very much as a not a
juggle but but uh conducting these two
extreme opposites
delicately together you know so the
other thing that's terrific in this
movie I think is your Tar Heel accent
how did you get that it's spectacular
I work with a really terrific voice
coach to actually on this film because
the the chap I usually work with Tim
Monaco ISM just a master at his trade
gave me wonderful recordings that I
listened to endlessly endlessly
endlessly just to get the sort of sounds
and he gives you these brilliant
exercises that train the muck the mouth
muscles to make shapes that you're just
not used to it's interesting you know if
you have an accent your muscles in your
mouth are only used to making certain
shapes and you have to train the mouth
to take on other shapes and then Liz
Hammerstein was with us during the
filming of the of genius and she was
there being my ears every day and
tweaking and helping me Laura Lily to
was actually from a town very near
Asheville and so having her on set was
very help she's pretty plays we should
say she plays programs his wife Perkins
wife but you know it's very interesting
just to combine both
the text of wolfs books and also the the
challenge of getting the accent right I
was advised early on to when practicing
the accent to recite from his literature
and what it enabled you to do was to try
and hear how this man spoke and of
course he famously used barely any
punctuation so his his sentences would
start and continue until he ran out of
breath and then and and would sometimes
also take on you know going completely
opposing directions and it was it was
wonderful at times to feel that you
could hear him in the room and I also
read a lot of his letters a lot aloud
and again he would write these pages of
letters and it was it was a it was a
good way to conjure him up it it was
until I agreed to do this and started
thinking about meeting you that it
suddenly occurred to me that you
actually have played a North Carolinian
before have Inman in in coal mountain so
was that a help it was it was a familiar
again going back to the rather technical
discussion the mouth the muscles in
one's mouth it was
yes it was it was a sound I had acquired
and one that I really enjoyed I you you
were able to pick it back up yeah I mean
I went back to work from from square one
because it felt right because it had
been 13 years gosh yeah 30 years since
cold welding so I started from square
one but it was also a sound that I
enjoyed I haven't always done accents
that I particularly enjoyed but I liked
it very much we actually have a clip
from coal mountains
[Music]
pretty great but it must have been an
immensely difficult part I mean it by
the end you are it's some of that makeup
but it's not all makeup I mean you have
literally been through it right hmm
yeah it was an interesting experience it
was very well considered by everyone you
know on the behind the camera as to how
to capture this immense journey and time
scale and they were they were really
considered well led by the wonderful
Anthony Minghella who I know you wanted
to talk about tonight um he he at the
front he was very considerate of his act
as always and knew that it was vital to
capture the different chapters of that
story in the correct order so you know
we wish we kind of started at the
beginning and when filmed it more or
less in order well kind of in that we
certainly filmed all the stuff before
the war when they were sort of young and
naive if you like and we shot all that
first of all and then I sort of went off
on my way and would meet up with ant and
we'd go off and film over this period
the oh sorry then we then we shot the
conflict that the sequences in the
conflict and then yes it was almost like
the that the carrot the actors sort of
split into two and and would go off and
shoot with the women Nicole and Rene and
and everything that happened back at
home and then would come go off on the
road with me and and continue on the
sort of
the journey of Inman and yeah it was
grueling it was from for months and
months we started in July and finished
by Christian Chris at Christmas so what
made you want to take that on
just the sheer challenge other or the
churches to work with well Anthony and I
had met in in he's the the film he did
prior to that and we've had a really
extraordinary experience that was
talented talented mr. Ripley yeah yeah
we have that too that's what we can
watch
we're going backwards go back and he he
he and I struck up a wonderful
relationship and
you know I'm probably stating the
obvious you you that's what you look for
you look for a director that you can
trust that you know is going to test you
and but also he's going to catch you and
push you and but ultimately be be in the
hands of someone who will encourage
great work you hope you know and then
you look at the subject matter and the
content and in this case it was this
fantastic book this beautiful book that
Antony had elegantly and exquisitely
adapted into a screenplay and of course
the part which as you rightly mentioned
was just a wonderful challenge the thing
I loved about him and that always made
me laugh
and again going back to accents whilst I
did work very hard on that accent I
barely said a word in the whole film
because he's suffering from this injury
and also because he's on his own for
most of the time but there was something
light and it's not a talkative garden
he's not a chatty blow no he's not he's
better you're absolutely right he's a
man of action or a few words and so it
was there was also this wonderful
challenge of capturing this this man's
journey this emotional scarring this
emotional spiritual depletion really
at the hands of conflict in a world that
he just saw tearing itself apart through
through physicality and that was the
challenge and it was a one it was
wonderful one to embark on it was also
fun to be in such extraordinary extremes
of nature we were filming in all
different terrain it wasn't filmed we
filmed some of it in the swamps of
Virginia we shot a majority the majority
of it in Romania because Anthony was
looking for a terrain where that's all
they have very similar
environments natural environments but
but Romania at the time we was just
coming out of the Tri Chesky regime and
Church s could force most of the
Romanians into the cities and so in fact
the countryside was almost untouched as
Antony said there were no tattoos of man
anywhere so there were no pylons or
roads and we my friend Ben who is here
with me Ben and I shared an apartment a
little house there we we were the only
we only had we're the only people with a
car in the village everyone else had
horse and carts and we were given milk
in a pail every morning that we had to
pasteurize or been pasteurized actually
and I mean it was pretty basic you know
and and there were families still out in
the meadows hoeing hoeing the the crops
you know
so how did you meet Miguel in the first
place the first time I was aware of
Anthony was actually through my mother
my mom was a teacher originally and then
decided to take up a follow her passion
for theatre and she set up a theater
company and one of her first plays was a
little like drowning which was one of
Anthony's first plays and she wrote to
Antony and asked for some advice and him
in his typical embracive and passionate
way invited her over for lunch and
talked her through the entire play and
so I remembered then his name and I
remember seeing the play and I was a
familiar familiar with him and his work
and then
I'm embarrassed to say it to say this he
so he came to I was working with his
wife seen this very odd little British
film with it with a Chinese director and
his wife was producing it and he offered
me the part of Dickie Greenleaf in the
talented mr. Ripley and he'd just won
he'd just won like nine Oscars for the
English Patient and I turn down the part
I don't know why I think I was I think I
I don't know what I was thinking I I
think if I'm honest I was you know I was
like twenty five or six and I sort of
thought it was a I don't know I thought
it was a part that played too much on
just good looks and it wasn't real it
wasn't a lot to it and he thank goodness
he came and saw me and sort of thought
me through the possibilities in this
role and and we embarked on what ended
up being a wonderful creative
collaboration we did Ripley we did Cold
Mountain and then we did his his final
film before he passed away
Breaking and Entering we have a clip
from Ripley let's look at that
I've seen
I rewatched this myself the other day
and occurred to me in retrospect there's
a maybe a tiny bit of Tom wolf Thomas
Wolfe in Dickie Greenleaf he's a jazz is
about to meet today's exuberant ease you
know he's a bit of a legend so
self-centered it's yeah it's funny I
hadn't made that connection you're the
second person who said that today I
think because you know I tend to leave
as happy as the experience may be the
exact film was um a long time ago now
and I haven't seen these clips in years
and years and so I suppose Dickie was
pretty much out of my system
and and therefore didn't necessarily
make the connections with Thomas Wolfe
but sure there are there are
characteristics there I read somewhere
around the time of this movie Minghella
said about you something like your
greatest obstacle as an actor was your
looks by which he meant I think that
that he worried that you know that you
could be typecast only as a leading man
and and and that people would not know
what a very good actor you are besides
being a very good-looking one it's a
nice problem to have a lot but has it
worked out that way in your career do
you think do you think that that you
have had have you had to struggle to get
out from underneath that or was it it's
a it's a very uncomfortable and odd
it's a conversation to have in a way
because by by discussing it is like
confirming that I think I'm this
incredibly good-looking you know I mean
although I have to say looking at that
which I can at the age of 43 I was very
pretty back then but you know like
anyone you wake up and you you love your
face you hate your face you you know
your face is your face and you I mean I
would also add that you know the thing
with the thing that looks in the in an
acting career is that they you know that
there are unconventionally
unconventional looking actors who have
fantastic careers because their
unconventional looking so it's not
always a given that Oh stink you're
good-looking therefore you're going to
have this wonderful career or not get
offered I think in the end you'll found
out and it's it's there for what you
choose to do and and and what you
deliver and sure there was it there was
a time when well I think turning turning
down that part initially was was was a
perfect example of this there was a time
early on when I thought oh I can I
should only do character roles I should
only do really odd ugly people so that
you know everyone takes me seriously and
then of course you realize that you're
kind of
you know you're cutting your own
Achilles heel then it's like it's like
just get on with it and see what comes
your way but equally choose wisely and
carefully I think probably my favorite
of your recent movies is Dom Hemingway
and Lord I wish I wish we could have a
clip of that I'm not surprised you down
the opening monologue we didn't know how
fine the the well it's it's hard to
explain it except that you play this
this kind of second-rate
safecracker who gets out of jail and but
part of what makes it so wonderful is
you seem to be taking terrific pleasure
and you look really seedy in this movie
you seem really to be enjoying that well
it was in true what was lovely was
thinking okay you know you've got to
create the face of a man who spent 16
years in prison who's been drunk for
possibly 25 years of his life
and bears the scars of all sorts of you
know injuries and mistakes and problems
and so sitting with a very talented
makeup artist and just looking at how
you put all of that on in into the face
and without wearing prosthetics it's fun
because then you feel like you've got
the mask of the character and once
you've got that mask you can you
disappear into him or her the other
great thing about this movie is is that
he has these monologues that yeah I mean
they're like they're like the monologues
in a play yeah like more than him they
reminded me the exact and I think that's
something that really appealed to me you
know he loved the sound of his own voice
and he reminded me of a sort of full
staff Ian kind of a drunk who would and
was also even though he was an
uneducated man and not a man he probably
read very much he he had a wonderful way
with words and Richard Shepherd who
wrote it and directed it really embraced
that that type of drunk and I thought
you know put some beautiful words
together there was a lot of fun to learn
and a lot of fun to play it to has a
wonderful accent well that's my that's
where that really that's you're at one
thing I said to Richard was because at
the time I read it he he kind of got his
geography of London wrong in fact you
know he had been to London but he'd said
this while it sort of looking at a map
and didn't real anyway and I kept saying
no if this guy's from here he can't go
there and he would know but you know so
he went back and I took him to the part
of London I grew up southeast London and
I grew up in an area called lewisham but
we decided to put Dom in an area called
Woollett he so he's I gave him a woolly
tracts and there were guys I went to
school with who I'm sure became chaps
like Dom Hemingway because well they was
pretty terrifying when I knew them as a
as a boy so when you're a boy going to
school with these terrifying guys do you
already know that you're gonna be an
actor when did that that's why I was
terrified of them I was this pretty
blond kid called Jude he wanted to be an
actor
[Laughter]
full of enthusiasm about the theater and
films and I usually got thumped by them
yeah I knew I knew pretty but a very
young age that it was something I wanted
to follow I had parents who were
teachers and who were great enthusiastic
for theater and film and I grew up being
taken to the theater a lot and going to
the cinema a lot and it was just a
passion I was a real sponge for it I
loved it and then that the first
opportunity as a kid in school putting
on plays it just felt like a
a dialogue a place where I was
comfortable I remember putting on plays
as a class with the teacher obviously
directing and just thinking it didn't
feel like class this felt like play and
it felt easy it felt comfortable I felt
at home and I guess as soon as I made
the connection that that could also be a
job that you would do it
it seemed like um an obvious direction
to go in
and then you know the passion takes over
when when you also realize there's a
snot serious element but an element of
you can you can actually have a voice
you can you can bring bring a voice to
things that you care about people that
you care about subject matters that you
care about so unlike a lot of British
actors of your generation you you didn't
go to the Royal Academy you didn't go I
mean you started quite young actually
learning on the job right yeah yeah I
was a member of the National Youth Music
Theatre from the age of 13 which was a
company 1213 and we were a comfort that
was a company that still operates and we
would meet during the holidays and
improvise and put on theater that we
would then take to festivals around the
country and
I got offered a job on TV and I left
school you parents are okay with that
they were his teachers it was very
interesting I think they knew that it
was something I took very seriously and
I think we agreed that if it all went
wrong I agree that I would go to my
education and and that was it I didn't I
didn't really stop I did an awful lot of
theater first
I mean film didn't seem like a reality
but you know I would go and see movies
all the time but being a film actor or
being in a having a film career just
didn't seem realistic in Lewisham it
felt like a distant
it felt like a you know something that
happened a lot well it did happen a long
long way away but it just didn't seem
conceivable to get into that world
whereas theater you know you drove pot
you drive past theaters all the time as
you do here in New York and in London
there they are so the even the idea of
going and asking for a job seemed
impossible and it it felt also that I
was following look not that I did it
necessary consciously but following in
the footsteps of a British tradition of
cutting my teeth on the stage and I'm
really grateful for that I feel that it
enabled me to become much more aware of
the
the mechanics of being an actor and the
demands of being an actor and
and also their respect for the process
in the craft of being an actor were
there people that you you took as models
with yet were there actors that you
particularly admired and trust certainly
I mean as a child I was a huge fan of
Paul Newman and Steve McQueen I mean I'm
going to say all the obvious ones I mean
the greats and and then and then the
generation of British actors ahead of me
people like Gary Oldman Tim Roth Daniel
day-lewis were huge heroes Sean Penn
I think I think the thing I loved about
them in particular was the variety of
roles they were playing that none of
them seemed to you know I remember in
one year seeing my beautiful laundrette
and then run with a view and I just
couldn't believe it was the same actor
who had done both and and having that in
mind the opportunity of keeping yourself
guessing and keeping your audience
guessing as to what you would do next
and you see especially lately to be sort
of making a point of continuing to act
on stage right I mean it wasn't that
well I loved it I mean it's not making a
point I it's a place I was quite
surprised not one like I was I was
surprised
that I'd left it so long there was a
window at some point I can't remember
where I I you know film work had had
become available and suddenly it had
been years a year since I'd done a play
and that wasn't through any planning it
was just the way it had been and I was
keen to get back to the theater and then
and then it became
and then I think someone approached me
the idea of returning and playing Hamlet
and I was suddenly very scared that
actually I'd left it I didn't want to
leave it too late I didn't want to be an
actor playing Hamlet in his mid to late
40s I thought that but you know that's
too too too long to leave it so and I
had such a great time playing that with
and with Michael Grandage directing that
it just reminded me of how much I loved
that process weren't terrified to be
Hamlet of course but you know I get but
I'm terrified every to eat
there's always an interesting journey
where you were very excited about the
idea and then the day you say yes you
become immediately regretful why have I
taken this on I'm gonna I'm gonna fail
miserably and then particularly in
rehearsals for a play you're two weeks
in you haven't quite you haven't quite
mastered the text you're still so
checking you're trying things out you're
spending your whole time at home pacing
around worrying running lines and you
and people are buying tickets and you
said anything this is this is disaster
and all you can do is block out the fact
that at some point you're gonna have to
go onstage and perform this and just
follow the process you know but whatever
realized is that that terror
that fear is why I do it I really mean
there can't be there can be no other
reason that it's mastering that fear and
getting to the point where you think
well either I'm gonna give it my all and
I'll fail miserably and that's fine at
least I've tried or it's gonna be a
triumph and it will be a wonderful
experience for everyone you know one of
these that has always fascinated me is
it's the difference between film acting
and stage acting and over the years I've
I've asked a lot of actors about that
and I've got a million different answers
and I've been told it's all pretty much
the same it's all acting oh no it's it's
night and day
film is easier stage it's a harder other
way around what is it for you what's the
difference in what's the appeal well
there I think I think both answers are
true I think they're very similar in
ways and incredibly distant I mean I for
me I think the clearest difference is
that directing is very much
film is a director's medium and film
usually
every film to me
has something to do with the director
that directed it and theater is an
actor's medium
in that you are as an actor allowed
through the journey of the rehearsal and
then the run of the play allowed to
inhabit an own a part that once the
director is left and I'm not saying you
suddenly you know putting all the bits
that you like that the director told you
to stop doing although you know that
happens too there's there's just a
greater sense of freedom that you are in
charge of this role at all times and
embody it for the entire duration that
you're on a stage rather than a role
being selected by an editor and a
director and if you like the performance
being steered by when and what an
audience see because of what makes the
final cut
also the biggest difference to me is
just the relationship with an audience
the magic you feel when you share an
experience together and that can be
affected by whether it's you know a
humid sticky hot evening where everyone
comes in and it's a hot theatre and or
indeed it's a cold wet night and and and
that affects this magic that happens
this alchemy that kind of happens across
from the stage to the to the auditorium
and the immediate appeal of that the
immediate sense of whether it's the
silence because of a dramatic moment or
the gasps because of a shocking moment
or the laughter because of a humorous
moment and the celebration at the end
that everyone's shared in it together
film has a lot more isolation than that
you know sometimes a person won't come
up to you for years and say oh I saw
that film and suddenly have an
opportunity to engage with your audience
member about something that you care
cared greatly about
yeah speaking of film directors you've
been around long enough and and that
you've worked with practically a who's
who of you know it's it's amazing so
it's I'm gonna leave them out but this
Scorsese and David Russell Joe Wright
Minghella
so Mendez
you know here are lots of who else bill
Berg Mike Nichols right Mike Nichols
exactly yeah so do any of them stand out
in particular or particularly memorable
or I wish I could get this right Mike
Nichols always said directors always ask
actors what other directors are like
because it's like asking what other
people are like I interviewed director
you ever get to speak with ourselves
yeah because they're monogamous yeah I
mean they're all what's wonderful is
that each has their own approach and
their own
[Music]
take on the medium and their own
requirements of you as an actor
and the jury Tamizh being is is is
having the opportunity to to to kind of
morph your process to fit their
requirements
and and and also you know as I said
before because it to me it's a
director's medium for those observing
the director at the helm creating this
piece of work it's also it's like slowly
you get to learn who they are and and
how they handle an extraordinary
situation I mean on the one hand you are
it's it's like being a sort of Roman
Emperor you know bring me a hundred for
mingoes and you know more light and you
know I want I want a river of blood
flowing that you know and everyone goes
yes okay we can have that tomorrow and
at the other half the others at the
other end of the spectrum they have you
know a thousand questions to answer
every minute and and it can you know
crush people so watching how they handle
it is very very interesting and draws an
awful lot of variety as you can imagine
out of the individual but
for me for me the most exciting element
sorry but the most exciting elements
about how they collaborate so I've two
directors I want to specifically ask you
about because of the two sort of
remarkable performances one is is is Joe
Wright in on a Karenina that was a you
know a movie that offended the Tolstoy
purists I thought it was brilliant
and and not the least brilliant thing
about it was your portrayal of Karen in
which you know he's in most
understandings of the novel he's he's
just dry as dust he's boring he's no no
wonder she leaves yes
you almost almost in a way and some of
the interpretations in other screen
versions made to be the bad guy yeah
actually made to be the man who getting
in the way of the love strike right and
your performance it really changed my
reading of the book he turns out to be
sort of uncommonly decent and he's a
little buttoned-up but he's decent he's
humane he's there's much more going on
there than didn't one ever knew I wish I
could say credit for that's Tom Stoppard
yes hopefully yeah I mean he
he first of all he put that on the page
in his screenplay but but but also then
called me and schooled me in in his
perception of that character and he he
felt it was very important that that
triangle be be a triangle and that
Karenina was not as I as I just
punctured you the man in the way but was
in a way the reminder at Ohana that
she's making a mistake she's going down
that that that she's seduced to go down
the obvious path the pathway in a remind
all not a reminder to the viewer of the
film to I mean you see and also Tolstoy
let's not forget was really interested
in the decent man the man bettering his
beloved Russia going out into the Urals
and counting sheep literally and making
sure that that everyone was eating and
that think that Mother Russia was - had
some structure to it Karenin is exactly
that he's actually doing the the
frankness job
sure he's boring right and and as they
describe in court like clockwork but
he's a good man the other movie I wanted
to ask you about is a very odd one which
is The Imaginarium of Doctor Parnassus
Terry Gilliam movie Terry Gilliam is
somebody I've interviewed a couple of
times and he said this sort of
star-crossed career and and and this
movie in particular it began with Heath
with starring Heath Ledger and Heath
Ledger died during the making of it and
so you Johnny Depp and Colin Farrell all
stepped up and played the Heath Ledger
part extraordinary
generosity I thought and and the thing
about the movie
you watch it first you think well that's
kind of weird and then you forget about
it and you're all in it works I mean I
mean fortunately because it was a Terry
Gilliam film I don't think that would
work you know in almost anyone elses
you're in this sort of incredible
fractured world of his of his
Imaginarium I mean talk about a film
representing a director Terry's are such
a clear you know they're like pounds of
flesh they're there they're his they're
parts of insights into his extraordinary
imagination it was also
eerily
as I suppose that when Heath passed away
he had shot only a particular section
that the film if you haven't seen it
takes place in reality and then there
are several scenes once they go through
the mirror of Parnassus --is Imaginarium
and all the stuff in the mirror hadn't
been filmed so Heath had had kind of
done the the groundwork and created this
character who then would take characters
or go on these adventures in Liam in The
Imaginarium and what became apparent was
we could therefore step into his shoes
literally and finish the piece because I
had a relationship with with Heath I
don't know that Colin and Johnny did
they certainly had a relationship with
Terry Terry and I had a relationship
with Terry as well so it just felt like
a very beautiful opportunity to have
complete something because we were aware
of as you say Terry Starcross career and
all fans of Terry's work
and also an opportunity to complete a
work for a for a fellow actor who left
us you know untimely so at this point in
your career presumably you can kind of
pick and choose what you want to do so
what do you look for when when somebody
it comes to now what do you put
well this is kind of the still the same
equation really right you know the
director and what the directors done and
what the director hopes to do with with
the project at hand and the script the
part I mean I'm still really excited to
try new things and play characters that
scare me as we said before and what's
exciting about getting older is of
course you get to also retread perhaps
characters that you played before but 20
years older and see you know obviously
they're not the same characters but see
where they're at now in their life I
think also the pressure of you know
playing that this sort of obviously the
bright young thing is behind behind you
so you you can look more to the know
that not that characters over the age of
40 so they become character you know
character roles and not lead roles but
they just become well they've lived a
little so I I'm just interested and
excited to continue stretching myself
you you seem and
maybe it's just an accident you seem to
go back and forth between kind of
popular movies big big movies and then
more independent kind of smaller movies
that deliberate or is it just you just
looking for the best part I take two
just try and look for the best part I
mean sometimes you know you it makes
sense it's a kind of a business decision
to keep yourself
connected to bankable projects so that
you can help bankroll the smaller
projects that that just seems to make
sense and I think it's something that
most actors in director or anyone
involved in film would would agree would
agree is necessary to consider our last
clip is from a film that that I think
does both it's a it's immensely popular
and it's a wonderful part but this is
and I don't know which one this is one
of the the Sherlock Holmes okay
movies with Robert Downey jr.
[Music]
part of the charm of these movies is the
chance to see two world-class actors
playing off one another is it does it
feel that way when you're doing it it's
yes they're great fun to make yeah he's
he's an extraordinary man and it was
quite it was quite interesting because
we developed this process of work
working together which I have to say
obviously involved guy and the producer
line Allegra manned and Susan Downey and
one of the other producers and Roberts
wife but we would we would take the
scenes at hand and we would improvise
them and sort of plate play around and
we would use what we called the Bible of
we had this Conan Doyle Bible which
which held all these little quotes and
one-liners and snippets from all the
books that we loved and replace our
dialogue with his and take more
contemporary dialogue and replace it
with more period dialogue and then edit
it and so it was a it was a hugely
collaborative experience and but working
with Robert is astonishing I've never
known someone come up with so many ideas
so quickly and try be just fearless in
what he was willing to try
try out and yeah sometimes it was a case
of just holding on and trying to keep up
and other times it was a case of just
being astonished though he was brave
enough to come up with an idea that you
thought will work and something usually
did are there gonna be any more of them
we hope so we were hoping to do another
this year but scheduling has not been in
our favor so I think he still has to
save the world as Ironman a couple more
time
man we might do something in 2018 yeah
but there's certainly an idea we've been
working hard on a really good idea but
of course at the heart of it all was
just what are these two guys - no it's
it's if we realize when we're working on
them it's not so much about the
adventure is more about just what
situation can we put these bickering
couple in that's right they are like a
married couple
well that's what we realized was so
attractive that whilst they're you know
under a bullet fire and what happy
they're actually arguing over the
washing or who who turned the the gas
off and meanwhile you're the Pope right
am i right about this I am okay
[Laughter]
I well I was the pipe buzz that's done
had to give my garments back so we yeah
we the members a miniseries right yes
it's uh I think nine part HBO miniseries
written and directed by Paolo Sorrentino
who was the wonderful director behind
the great beauty and el Divo and I don't
know how much I can give away because
I'm still not sure when it's going to be
aired I believe either end of the year
or beginning of next but it's about the
fur it's a fictitional piece looking at
the life of the first American Pope who
is a young New Yorker called Lennie
Bilardo who is also an orphan and it's
about his crisis his it was interesting
to tackle I needed Lee thought goodness
what have I got to read to study to play
a pope so youyou obviously reach
immediately for the Bible
and yet that gives you know quite well
it gives you guidance but not the kind
you necessarily and then you think you
know is there a pope school one away
where I go I didn't know where to start
and powerless said a very interesting
thing which was that you know it's about
the man so in fact it was more about
creating a real man and because it's
really about this individuals dilemma
and he happens to be the Pope so that's
where we started but it was a wonderful
peace and wonderful to work with power
lovin I think we have some time for some
questions and I've also got some
questions from the internet or Facebook
I'm sorry the the way the questions work
is I think they're going to have
microphones
and you need to if you want to have a
question you need to come down and speak
into the microphone
so meanwhile they're getting ready
here's one from Facebook what was the
toughest character you've played to date
III think I would probably put Karenin
up there
well I mean Hamlet was challenged right
but but on film Karenina because Joe had
such a clear sense of for him being this
contained emotional swallowing kind of
ghost of a man and I think I have a
tendency to want to to to take to take
my characters honor on a clear emotional
journey and Joe's idea was always to
really restrain and the restraint was it
was was was complex and hard
question-there hello three times I
crossed the pond to see you in Hamlet
alone Christie and Henry the fifth I'm
pushing 88 years will you bring the
obsession to Broadway and save me the
energy that's the perfect reason to
bring it
there's a chance I certainly think there
is a chance yeah good job we're already
going so we start that in in London at
the Barbican we go we do we do three
very short trips around Europe we go to
Amsterdam this is a production I'm doing
with Eva von hos before he's like I
haven't known its crucible on Broadway
yeah it's just a man and he did a
wonderful production of view from the
bridge brilliant so I'm pretty sure we
will bring it I've not were with him
before no he approached me last year and
had this idea of taking Visconti's
obsession and putting it on stage as
only he could
question over here it's an easy to call
but yeah
hi I'm not sure if you're aware that
Wilde had a huge impact on the gay
community here in New York no huge and
um I just wonder I know it's a while ago
but what was it like for you at that
point in her career to be playing a
character that
I mean we talked earlier about you know
being cast for physical beauty but also
the emotional depths that this man you
know and the kind of size of the
character yeah it was an awfully huge
thing for someone so young to be
tackling could you talk a little bit
about what that is why
at the time it was that were all those
elements were what excited me
and
why I was fascinated by him because on
the one hand you know you had Oscar and
the majority of the piece talking about
this how exquisite this young boy was
and beautiful and like an angel and
untouched and yet everything I read
about him
and indeed history which speaks louder
than anything made it very clear that he
was the most poisonous nasty you know
talentless little imp I think you know
in in in in literary history actually I
was just remembering today someone gave
me a book of his poems as a gift and
they are atrocious and yet he has the
audacity to try and store Oscar Wilde
publications because he he said that you
know he needed to have the the spotlight
for a while but as a young actor it was
I mean I'll be honest I look back I was
talking 24 when I when I played bossy
and there was a certain amount of blind
fearlessness
but the the challenges were what really
excited me I think and I was also very
aware that it was a great opportunity to
put this although it was sadly tragic
but this great love story on the fit on
film for possibly the first time and
also honestly where we can actually we
could show their physical love their
physical attraction and the physical
world
the the the the sexual world that Oscar
inhabited in London albeit behind closed
doors and elicit it was it felt
incredibly important to put all of that
outlet so I'm thrilled that you say that
it had that relevance thank you thank
you
here's a this is a question from
Facebook do you ever think about
directing yourself and if and if you
were going to direct is there anything
that you would want to try you know I I
thought about it a lot and more so
recently and
there are there's a project I have in
mind it's it's a more a case of
not finding the time because I'm
terribly busy but finding the time when
I know that it's in the right shape and
I'm in the right shape and it's a it's a
complicated process but the more I kind
of dwell on it
the more first of all I'm certainly it's
something I want to do and the more I
remind myself to get a move on and just
and just do it the one thing I hear is
that it is always the most wonderful
experience terrifying but wonderful so I
I'm certainly curious to moving that
into that area yes
okay first off I wanted to say that I
think you're one of the most charming
British actors I have ever had the
pleasure of meeting and speaking on the
movie genius even I would say charming
we could take British out we could just
say take and my role as editor I'm going
to delete write and speaking on the
movie genius even though you play an
editor did you ever have a favorite book
from either Hemingway or Fitzgerald did
I ever have a favorite a favorite book
I'm not an editor in it I pay a writer
all right I'm calling plays the editor
but
[Music]
yes the beautiful and the damned I think
is my favorite Fitzgerald
Hemmingway my favorite hemingway god
I'm possibly the Sun Also Rises all
right
another one from Facebook which asks it
talking about your your role in in spy
when you play the straight man to
Melissa McCarthy and whether you and it
sort of ties in a little bit to the to
the Watson character do you ever do you
think about doing more comedy
yeah
it it's not necessarily something
because I haven't because I haven't
played an out-and-out comedic role it's
not something that comes my way I think
people would read a comedic script or
and and very often nowadays comedies are
what's the word they're sort of created
from from source by the lead comedian
comedian who's goes you know domain it
becomes a vehicle that's the word you
know you've done Hemingway sir comment I
suppose Dom Hemingway is a comedy of
sorts yeah and I like to think of you
know there are a lot of Sherlock Holmes
that has somebody in it
a part I really want to play on stage is
Benedict in much ado about nothing I
love the last scene in Henry the fifth
there's a you know that the comment
there's a huge comedic scene at the end
of Henry the fifth the wooing scene with
Princess Catherine and I loved I loved
it every night it was a great breath of
relief release so yeah I'm always
looking for different challenges we only
have questions on this side I guess
there's no hi dude thank you for being
here my question for you is what is your
advice for upcoming or new actors I
always say
you know
no no matter no matter you know getting
getting your foot in the door and
getting professional work is always hard
so in a way what I'm going to say may
sound like likely obvious or also the
impossible but keep doing it is really
important what I mean by that is even if
you're if you're not getting the
professional work look for productions
look look for the opportunity to
continue to act and only then you know
first of all you're you're flexing that
muscle you're exercising that muscle
that you are passionate about you're
constantly learning it's constantly an
opportunity for people to see you and
there are always things going on there
are always people doing stuff and don't
be embarrassed about writing right I
wrote endless letters to directors to
both both just just saying what I was
doing asking to meet them and their and
you know if you write enough letters you
end up getting the opportunity to meet
people I got I got replies from I have
memories of various directors in
theatres and so on around London who
were generous enough to meet me and
guide me and and all of that just keeps
the opportunity the belief that
something will happen and can happen
alive
awesome thank you good luck
what would you say is one of your
craziest and most unexpected lessons
that you've learned over the course of
your career
about work
No
a craziest lesson that's really or the
toughest
yeah
I think
I think it's the receipt tricky one to
put into yeah
I suppose
referencing Robert Downey again the you
know the idea of keeping yourself
away from the obvious
you know that the the obvious is is
always glaring you in the face and it's
kind of what everyone's expecting you to
do it's what you're expecting to do and
it's a safe place to go and the
eventually if all your ideas run out
you're going to end up going there
anyway so I suppose the lesson is to
keep yourself
keep challenging yourself and I mean in
the moment whether it's a choice in a
scene whether it's in a part you take
what you say no to what you say yes to
do you see what I mean it's constantly
keeping yourself guessing because the
path the obvious path will always be
there to tread yeah
but
hi first of all I really loved you in
enemy at the gates which for some reason
people in the state don't always but I
have a weird question I guess I was
wondering if you ever did voiceover for
like kind of future animated film and if
you would consider doing it mmm
I I did I've done it a couple of times I
did it once for a little kids film
called rise of the Guardians in which I
played the bad guy much to the horror of
my sister's youngest son who loved that
film I think he was like 4 when it came
out I've hated that character and my
sister can tell him that it was her
because she was very scared that he'd
never let me back into the house on
Christmas and then I just did I just I
was just part of a really eccentric and
exciting project that Ezra Koenig who's
the lead singer of Vampire Weekend he
wrote and conceived this animated series
that's about to start
I believe on Netflix called neo yoky Oh
have you heard about it yeah I played so
I think Jamie Smith is playing this
little boy called Kai in it and I'm the
I'm his butler I'm this kind of huge
robot Butler called Charles who is also
a rocketship and it takes place in a New
York that is sort of combined with Tokyo
in the future
so the last question the last question
from Facebook are one of mr. law's plans
for dinner but how can you how can you
be asking that on Facebook you're gonna
have dinner on Facebook I don't
understand anyway thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]